hey youtubers it's Charlie Happy
Holidays there's a new Game of Thrones
Season 6 teaser HBO just dropped it's
not quite as big as the Jon Snow teaser
like releasing that image of him like oh
yeah he's definitely coming back but
this is all about bran and I think it
implies a big change from the book just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far and
in everything that the show has done
we're really talking through Dance with
Dragons but before winds of winter in a
new round of the giveaway starts now
it's just a $20 Amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
what's the big deal about this teaser
it's just an image of brand riding a
horse wait wait a minute something
sounds wrong about that the last time we
saw bran
he was underneath the weirwood with the
Bloodraven learning about his green site
a lot of you have also pointed out that
his haircut is different so maybe the
children of the forest run a really
awesome day spa and maybe the Bloodraven
just likes his hair really long and
being ingrown with a lot of the trees so
here's where we get into a little bit of
book talk so they've already subtracted
Coldhands from the brand story line when
bran is going to see the green seer the
last screens here for the first time or
the Bloodraven however you want to think
about him cold hands is the one that
takes them to the cave as opposed to the
TV show where you just got the child of
the forest who is just like here come in
here you'll be safe and if it's not
clear that skeleton at the end of season
4 that was a reanimated white a servant
of the great other
so when bran goes to see the last green
seer and learn about his destiny it's
heavily implied that he is going to be
stuck in that cave for the rest of his
life because it looks like the
Bloodraven has been there ever since he
left the watch now remember he came to
the watch at the same time maester aemon
did but he's much much older
he's one of maester aemon's uncles and
he is at this point in the story the
Bloodraven is probably one of the oldest
living people that we know about so even
though you're led to believe that bran
is going to be helpful in the war for
the dawn it seems like he's gonna be
stuck underground so why would the TV
show show him on a picture with a
haircut on a horse in broad daylight
like what's what's going on here
my thought is is they're gonna take a
couple liberties with brands education
that they'll still be doing the same
things that they do in the book that the
last green seer will teach him about his
powers that he doesn't know about his
power over nature the children of the
forest the war with the great others
like the big war of Ice and Fire but
are going to let him travel around the
north a little bit just in service a
visual diversity of composition so I
guess maybe they're afraid that you know
him being a relatively important
character having to shoot all of his
scenes in this dank dark cave in this
root system would just be super boring
that to me is just like the most
practical take away looking from from
what this image is telling us but it
could be something even simpler you have
to remember though they're pushing into
winds of winter territory they haven't
read that book like Georgia our Martin
hasn't revealed all the secrets of that
book so even if he finishes it before
season six starts they pretty much
finished filming season six so as we
watch episodes especially with brands
storyline which is now pushed past Dance
with Dragons we'll have to see what
changes they made from the books I'm not
gonna do too much book stuff during
season six
if wins winners release I mean I'll
still do book videos but if you haven't
read the books before if season six
starts just wait till after season six
because they're going so far off book
that it's probably only gonna confuse
you so if you really want to read the
books who wouldn't want to start just
wait till after season six episode ten
but I just think it's kind of funny that
they released this brand image like
after I'd done a couple Bloodraven
videos and I haven't talked about it too
much yet but I know there are a lot of
theories that the Bloodraven
might be a servant of the great other
like like bran might realize that he's
serving someone evil like oh my god
you're fighting with the White Walkers
the reason people think that is because
of a vision that Melisandre has and
there's this line from the book where
the Blood Ravens talking to brand Brett
says there he sat listening to the
hoarse whispers of his teacher never
fear the darkness bran the Lord's words
were accompanied by faint rustling of
wood and leaf a slight twisting in his
head the strongest trees are rooted in
the dark places of the earth darkness
will be your cloak your shield your
mother's milk darkness will make you
strong so a lot of people are just
saying like wow he mentions darkness
several times in that sentence that
doesn't sound very good but I think it's
a little misleading I think that just
meant to imply that bran will be removed
from the daylight like he'll be stuck in
that cave so he will literally be in
darkness most of the time but just
because the Bloodraven has been
presented as this wise teacher like an
obi-wan kenobe figure thus far doesn't
automatically mean that he's a good
character so just keep your eyes peeled
and I'm so happy that they cast Max von
Sydow he's gonna be so amazing
if you guys didn't see him he was
totally in Star Wars Episode seven be
sure to go see that movie I've done a
bunch of videos for it already
but in related news if you guys didn't
see I just did a Benedict Cumberbatch
video that they released a couple Doctor
Strange teasers there's a couple other
trailers that I have to get through and
I'm out in like you know mandatory
family vacation time so all be posting
videos but it's not quite as many videos
as I normally would feel like the next
two days so I'll say congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Roy Arthur
you win a $20 Amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel for details and if
there's any other bonus videos you guys
want me to do this week just let me know
in the comments just in case you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for that Doctor Strange teaser that I
just posted and you can click here for
all my other Game of Thrones Season 6
teaser videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you